[Musique]
peinture un petit peu là tu vois je me
suis mauvais de la aux dames et des
symptômes douleur j'ai eu hier soir
continue à marcher sur la pointe des
pieds c'est tendu colin firth un petit
pot de remettre ça ce n'est pas son
problème sans problème
je suis sur moi j'aurais j'aurais pu le
suivre parce que je suis non mais
vraiment mais je trace et moi j'étais là
mais je pense que si le groupe b la bt
doit déchirer
c'est pas l'entente je pense que là je
dois arrêter facilement s'en vont vers
la troisième jour de marche
alexandre roy retraité de l'opéra de
paris soigne ses premières blessures de
guerre prévenir plutôt que guérir
c'est ça j'ai l'impression de retourner
à l'opéra aïda les chaussées des points
c'est horrible
l'étape de la veille en a surpris plus
d'un ce fut largement plus laborieux que
nos 18 marcheurs ne l'avait imaginé
on restait dans la finance et ça c'est
du moins lorsqu'on jette un coup d'oeil
à son sac
ce matin je me suis levé un peu plus tôt
je les vis des derrière je vais tout
réorganiser problème c'est qu'au moment
où je ferme chaque coup j'ai mis quoi
donc
après je vais chercher un tricks et puis
joueurs sortent ou alors c'était
organisé mais bon des majors faire une
autre dans l'autre rangement la claque
c'est une clope c'est trop non mais faut
donc bien couvrir ça quand même
ça va des résines j'avais plus d'essence
comme tout homme est bien c'est bon
d'avoir fait pas l'affairé mais oui
c'est normal c'est le groupe compétition
[Musique]
l'étape du jour consiste à relier le val
ferret à l'hospice du grand saint
bernard dans la peau de cole et 7 heures
demain sur le papier une étape un peu
moins éprouvante relatait dose de quoi
j'avais puis en avant tout
en voiture simone
mais tous les postes ne sont pas aussi
presse le groupe famille a décidé de
prendre son temps
je me suis réveillé en sursaut quand
j'ai entendu les autres tous commencé à
remuer
je n'avais plus du tout notion d' où
j'étais et ce qui m'attendait et moi qui
ai de la chance face à la réunion on a
pour beaucoup des jeunes beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup questionné jeudi un
récit très physique que la vie c'était
un si beau cadeau un long chemin qu'il
fallait la vivrai la mordre à pleines
dents chaque jour et en profiter
j'apprécie davantage ce jour en jour
parce que ça vient
avia kodwa qui prend 1 m on fait un être
piqué ce qui me reste maintenant il me
reste encore 25 cm mais
tout est possible
[Musique]
les violences
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez dit qu'on allait former les
groupes rac de fne
pourquoi cela
et là où sa drisse architectes paris se
rafraîchir les idées température
extérieure environ 15 degrés température
de l'eau disons 10 degrés pour faire là
je suis impressionné allez on essayait
un billet à la base il est courageux un
homme n ° fait je me mets pas si froide
que ça en fait
alors il prend part la pause la galerie
bonheur avec quelqu'un dont il nous fera
non je crois que c'est vrai que la
nature tu la prend en pleine tête la
cagnotte mais un chocolat on va faire
pour arriver avant 8 heures ce soir de
son groupe famille ne s'accordait métier
de prendre son temps
il prend carrément des retards pour
votre information les autres black soul
accidents sont co lamoura bédard
[Rires]
[Musique]
blues ont frappé pour une spécialité
locale qui fait la fierté de la région
la respiration s'en laisse pas conter
dans l'air une odeur de chocolat
[Musique]
ah non merde
mais de loin des résines s'il te plaît
régime du président l'artiste parisienne
affiche une nouvelle fois son impatience
à tollevast complète chemin
le programme je me vois plus je me bats
peut y a rien à faire à temps plein vent
trop fort
les marche toujours très élégant de
régime le pas sur très stable régulier
alors sur la manne et les apartés ça va
finir comme ça modularité
voilà vous verrez pas courir on verra
avant c'est monique juriste à la
retraite s'accroche comme il peut
au rythme des sons qu'on voit la régie
de la guide en fait j'aurais dû je vais
peut-être eu les deux guides
inconsciemment dans sa main tendue
voilà ce que pense surtout à gagner la
paix doit dire l'enfer
autre gage allure mais qu'est ce qu'il a
c'est quoi cette bête tout va mal c'est
marrant cette espèce de home cell est
tombé mais c'est trop court cette
recours aux avis il faut aller tous
libres penseurs peral ailleurs régine et
se rapproche de découvrir une loi
fondamentale
en montagne la ligne droite ce n'est pas
forcément la république
[Musique]
avec des cannes est là pour sa foi je
vais même passer en question je remets
autre chose en question tu sais très
bien ce que c'est on en a discuté hier à
discuter en manière c'était très calme
où j'allais rester un groupe tu le fais
pas tu le fais pas moi je vais pas
courir après tout le temps en plus je
vous y attends dit oui et alors oui le
problème ou qu'est ce que s'est dit
après qu'est-ce que tu m'a dit tu m'a
taquiné en me disant que je ne rentrais
pas de chemin
noël c'est pas méchant alors si tu me
prends comme ça bat empire je m'en
excuse peut-être parce que souvent ça
arrive quand les jambons devant ils
partent sur un autre chemin mais je ne
laisse pas pire oui mais là en
l'occurrence tu as pris ce chemin tu
hésites rd 100 la remontée je te
laissent un peu porter c'est tellement
et chaude je ne sais pas tu t'es pas
exténué jeu problème encore une fois
n'est pas là mais on en discuterait une
autre fois parce que là c'est le
déjeuner d'accord mais je ne sais quoi
comme boss ses vaches qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure la confusion de sa déjà vu
comment ce que tu as fait une croûte
d'herbes en microscopie n'krumah prépare
une route où les scooters améliorer mon
niveau
je vis les groupes de loin s'en faut ne
sont pas au bout de leurs peines un col
peut en cacher un autre
[Musique]
franchement ça grimpe même la bonne
cause en cour s'il a mis de la partie
live est tombé au débit d'eau en plus
ils sont mouillés ou décembre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est typiquement le genre de
parcours qui permet de complètement
déconnecté mais déconnecté par
l'épuisement peut-être cuisent
physiquement et a ordonné ton esprit les
prix uniquement par les éléments de base
quoi quand est ce que j'arrive quand
elle se range
j'ai mal là qu'est ce que je dois faire
pour était tout le reste tous les autres
problèmes qui sont des problèmes tu peux
avoir une certaine importance
il passe au second degré
[Musique]
le choix bravo à mon job je pensais pas
[Applaudissements]
super beau la nature mais ça regarde pas
ses pieds on tombe donc j'ai beaucoup de
mes pieds mes chaussures qui vont pas
fait mal et au bout d'un moment c'est
vrai que pousser l'effort comme ça on
arrête de réfléchir c'est vachement j'ai
pas j'ai l'impression de temps en temps
de l'es2 délester m'ont pas du poids de
mon sac à dos mais les types de douleur
pertes aude et des petits bonheurs enfin
des trucs qui remonte quoi et que je
vais pas revenir à paris
m
[Applaudissements]
la voilà c
malaga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrivée l'idée ou ce refuge pour pauvres
parisiens épuisé au consulat beaucoup
voilà c'est au coc aux vingt minutes on
rigole bien la mare à chaque fois qu'ils
en révèlent un chèque en bois
yoda la journée de repos rien à voir
c'était leur propos de guerrier
[Applaudissements]
2700 au plaisir quoi c'est nous locales
et or a les appels courage suivait les
arrivées il s'appelle week-end
ailleurs j'ai dépassé m'apportes
aujourd'hui pour dépasser sa fatigue
quoi et demain pour dépenser quoi on
veut bazire ces huit jours de vacances
près ce que c'est c'est de l'effort
fauchoux c'est de la souffrance quand
même faut pas se dire on va faire
chamonix-zermatt les donnant le nom
c'est pas vrai on y va bien vous le
croûton rencontre les comportements ont
cure et je peux t'endormir 30 secondes
vous poser sa patte il est d'autant plus
de bien que marcheur découvrez notre loi
fondamentale ne gagne pas très remonté
forcément une descente et la descente
n'est pas forcément un cadeau
j'ai appliqué par les blues j'ai passé
devant moi c'est pas du tout un problème
de vente à tort bien didier de cinq ans
attend tous avant l'esprit qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit la junior de descente a
plus à voir
besson a dit jamais la vérité
on ne méritait quelque peu élastique il
est vrai les guides sont parfois
condamnés à de purs mensonges pour
maintenir le moral des troupes
voilà on arrive au célèbre école de
fenêtres des tourbières brûlent à llano
[Musique]
la tradition ses deux fils et la
frontière
onze de mes gars est un pote pour les
filles c'est plus compliqué sa fleur
d'or bd ou du quai saint bernard il est
là donc c'était en fait un petit détour
qu'on a fait pour faire découvrir
l'italie malheureusement on va devoir
retourner sur n'ont pas non c'est
derrière le dans une folle au départ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monique aquila théo
régine avec un style toujours
particulier il en faut peu pour être
heureux vraiment très populaire il faut
satisfaire du nécessaire
c'est pur antillais elle a essayé de
chanter oasis eu du monde des rôles en
anglais la pauvre soleil il en faut oui
vraiment très très peu pour être heureux
tout ça fait une heure et demi qu'on
marche alors je suis censé pas la même
que la nôtre on arrive quand même en
bourse
et là c'est ça
comme ils sont gentils
bonjour bonjour ça va arriver au super
bien et me voir ils ont parlé de nous
être la nuit au tsoup au fond je crois
que c'était comme ça
[Musique]
les marcheurs navigue désormais sur une
autre même pousser définitivement
débarrassé de ce qui embarrasse
[Musique]
ça mange et on
ah ouais d'accord
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Musique]
c'est bien sous sa coupe
j'ai mal fait mon sac
si bien qu'à gauche on n'était pas
accessible fallait tout enlever le
matériel technique
donc j'ai pas vu pendant la montée au
jeu petit le conte ou écouter encore que
ce qu'aujourd'hui comme moi on a passé
la journée de panique le missile a
choisi une option plus un caillou parce
qu'il ya un concours de trouver des plus
pierre en forme de coeur avec isabelle
et les deux enfants
ouais je vois qu'il est trop jeune et
relativement de votre le plus porteur
après je suis vite
nous on le met 10 il a mis de côté parce
que c'est bon de ce côté c'est peut-être
des cures de pierre mais la nature nous
nous distribuent tellement d'amour
le prêt pour l'apéro valaisan quoi ça
les hôtes et chantaient j'avais emmené
thon rouge à lèvres
aujourd'hui j'ai fait mes coups de
cloche qu'on peut faire de moi ça veut
dire que j'ai économisé dayraut aussi un
alors j'ai décidé d'offrir des femmes
un petit cadeau à l'aide
[Applaudissements]
la bise à leur merci c'est sympa clément
c'est toi merci beaucoup
les gens nous tuer du coup c'est un peu
cliché mais ça vous va bien
[Musique]
pendant que les adultes se refont le
plein d'énergie
louise étaient eux ont déjà oublié leur
fatigue mais on est encore bien loin de
ce monde nous sommes même pas mis
partout j'ai le petit plus
[Musique]
affectueux
c'est génial intrants bernard on voit la
vie même
région
nous jouons
[Musique]
gros dénivelés petite frayeur pour le 4e
jour nous apprend des marcheurs prennent
de la bouteille et profite d'une étape
bucolique et s'entraîne avant
d'affronter la haute montagne
le tampon origine peut soigner ces
ampoules qui entreront dans les annales
et pour monique d'affronter la colère
qui monte au sein de son % à 65 ans la
doyenne de l'expédition fait chuter la
moyenne
il y a de la rébellion dans l'air